shane told me some of the things that
she had said and i actually called jayna
the day after and asked her you know did
you say these things and and she was i'm
dishonest in that phone call and she
denied saying most of the things she
actually did say yesterday shayna called
me and we were just essentially having
girls talk and she was just like
checking in essentially she was like i
have someone to hook you up with if
things don't work out with shane but
like that was such a weird comment i'm
not sure like why shane is trying to
cause drama for us
natalie how you feeling
feeling pretty good yeah i know it must
have been a tumultuous couple of months
what was it like watching your
your relationship play out on tv the way
it did um i went through a lot of
different emotions
um you know it's it's beautiful to see
all my best memories captured on screen
but it's definitely really hard you know
seeing
that relationship with shane again and
and you know just knowing the outcome of
it
let's go back to the beginning what was
it about him that attracted you to him
in those pods yeah i you know i think
a lot of it was the assurance he gave me
you know from the very beginning he said
it was going to be me um but i it was
also the loyalty to his family how much
he loved and cared for his mom and his
his brother and
um and you know also his kind heart you
know i think underneath
you know all of all of him he's he's
such a kind person
i feel like he had this journey of you
know in the first few episodes people
were like is he gonna be the villain
like is this guy gonna be
just like is it gonna be terrible you
know what was your family's reaction
watching these episodes play out in the
first few episodes you know the ones
um in the pods they were they were
pretty shocked they were like you know
that's not the shame that we met um and
then obviously when we get to the the
latter you know half of the episodes um
that that's kind of the shame that they
knew and they loved if it's not you i
don't think there's
anyone else here for me
whatever i have to do to prove to you
that i'm fully focused on you i will do
it what was the moment that you knew
that you could marry shane you know i
feel like i kind of knew from the
beginning
i know that's hard for viewers to see
you know there's so much that happened
to the beginning that that showed a lot
of you know our differences but i think
what's not shown is the deep
conversations we had you know he really
really understood me and i really
understood him and i felt like there was
a true partnership there i felt like he
always had my back and so from the very
beginning i could see see him as my
husband did you have any indication
during that time when you guys were
living in the apartment together
maybe it's not going to work out those
thoughts came in
and and went it really wasn't until you
know the fight um the day before the
wedding where you know it really
solidified
you know saying yes on our wednesday was
not
we just couldn't do it
we don't watch that fight as audience
members yeah but what can you tell me
about it i think the pressure of our
wedding also played a part into that
of you know feeling like we have to make
a decision really quickly
um you know
i think it just came down to our
differences i think just the feeling of
making a lot of compromises
um
may have gone into him and
and i think he held that in for
you know for a bit and it
it kind of came out that night was your
family in were they all in did they
had shane won them over by that point
prior to the fight
absolutely i think because of how
confident i was in the relationship and
um and just seeing how much she cared
for me and you know our moms got really
close um they they started texting every
day after meeting each other so i think
with all that you know they were so
supportive of the relationship
so i think it was really hard from them
um
you know
really
hard for them
knowing it wasn't going to happen to you
but they were very supportive of you
know my ultimate decision
do you feel like watching the show back
are there any moments that you look back
on and say like
yeah that was kind of a red flag right
there and
in the moment it didn't feel as big of a
deal but watching it back and with a
little bit of distance i absolutely see
where this sort of originated from
yeah so i think the situation in the
pods when uh shane
calls me shayna i think just watching
that as a viewer i
i didn't realize at the time how
unhealthy that conversation was did you
have any idea like how
close their relationship was no i had no
idea that they had a connection in the
pods beyond that situation um you know i
just thought like he was talking to
other women it was so early on but you
know after that i didn't i didn't know
that they had a connection no
and then we sort of had this beach
picnic where
you know i guess she had called you the
night before to say
that she had another guy for you if it
didn't work out how do you remember that
conversation with shayna that was off
camera
yeah so she called me after mexico just
to check in and she asked how shane and
i were doing you know it was girl talk
and then she told me about you know the
things that were happening with kyle as
well and um
she just said you know i
um if shane and you don't work out like
i have a friend who's a millionaire and
he's interested in you i showed him your
instagram profile and so if you're
interested you know you know he's he's
available so that's essentially what she
said um
and you know i thought it was a weird
comment but you know i kind of like
brushed it off just because i didn't
know the connection she had with shane
but you know as i was debriefing that
conversation with
um with shane you know i brought up that
comment and i was like i think it was
you know very weird what was his
reaction when you told him that
he was pretty mad and i didn't
understand it at the time i was like you
know i think she doesn't know us like i
think she just said it out of the blue
but now i understand you know why he was
irritated by that comment
she had designs on your man
that's what it looks like you know i
still don't know what her intentions
were um i haven't had the conversation
with her about it in terms of like where
her anger came from or why she called my
relationship fraudulent or you know fake
um
but i i didn't know the extent of that
conversation until i saw the show um so
that was that was a surprise for me
shane told me some of the things that
she had said and i actually called jayna
the day after and asked her you know did
you say these things and and she was i'm
dishonest in that phone call and she
denied saying most of the things she
actually did say so it was i was just
kind of in this weird place of like i'm
not really sure what happened but you
know um you know watching the show you
know i was very surprised that was a
sort of a pivotal moment that i think
probably won the audience over to shane
where shane was like
you know kind of gave her the brush off
and i think a lot of people applauded
him for that so overall would you say
this was a this was a good experience
how would you encapsulate your time on
the show i think overall
i'm so grateful for the experience i've
learned so much about myself it's been
such an amazing learning experience and
i feel like i've grown so much
from those eight weeks